le roi conserve quelques vérités 66
minutes ce que vous avez vu 66 minutes
il ya une fille qui arrêtent l'école
pour une raison surprenant de les voir
pourquoi cette jeune fille avec l'école
c'est incroyable et ça ça veut dire
voilà on y est ça y est on y est bairi
fait comme ça m est will have de vidéos
il a vu regarder mais je voulais pas
qu'on le dit aujourd'hui pour deux
raisons brianna arrêté l'école pour se
consacrer entièrement à tik tok
maquiller munis de faux ongles
brianna réalise une quinzaine de clips
chaque jour il est joli
sa mère est devenue sa manager elles
contrôlent tout écrit les commentaires
et post les vidéos
l'enjeu est important même si elles
refusent de nous donner le montant
rihanna avec ses deux millions de
followers pourrait gagner plusieurs
milliers de dollars par mois c'est ouf à
seulement 13 ans gars agraire et ouais -
m2 mais alors qu'est ce que vous en
dites quelle honte quelle honte
mais vous allez encore me dire oui c'est
magnifique je vous connais par coeur
mais c'est honteux fait merki exploite
sa fille et qui revit une jeunesse par
l'entremise de sa fille la petite dans
dix ans elle sera en pleine dérive
ouais arrêté savez peut-être ma lunaire
mais dans vos arguments franchement
qu'on puisse à développer une activité
artistique professionnelle après c'est
ça le seul bémol c'est l'école qu'elle
continue au moins jusque là mais qu'elle
puisse gagner de l'argent là où il me
pose aucun nom alors les manies mamie
chérissez elle ne fait rien de temps
c'est gravissime ce que tu dis ça veut
dire qu'on accepte une gamine soit
déscolarisés et ne fasse rien d'autre
qu'un truc qui va le clip de d'abord
qu'ils allaient finir par la rendre
complètement le noir et or du santé et
qui ensuite va la rendre c'est non
seulement un accompagnement du jura
maniement dévastateur cette gamine et
oui je mentalise et ça absolument un
scandale et vous savez syrie en france
via la jurisprudence genre dit oui parce
qu'on dit toujours dur d'être un bébé
c'est exactement il est encore chanter
les frères maintenant il a 30 plus ça
passe par là sauf qu'ils avaient gagné
beaucoup d'argent
il avait été poussé exploité par ses
parents qui ne laissait et ses enfants
s'est fait et cet enfant n'avait plus
d'argent avec sa majorité
ces oiseaux aujourd'hui quand un enfant
gagne de l'argent l'argent est bloqué
sur un compte et on n'a pas droit les
parents n'ont pas droit de toucher le
match silienou ce qui lui est arrivé et
bébé très importante
mag quant à maxime que t'es pas fait
d'études bon c'est ton problème tu as
mais là où cette année tu d'ailleurs
rien ça se voit vous connaissez un mec
qui vous laisse j'ai piqué côtés du
pasteur quoi les ambassadeurs de
l'industrie créative afin mastermind un
petit tube ça sert pas à grand chose
quoi comme diplôme un master de la tap a
eu ton dit à blake tombé ce soir je vais
vérifier
je vais tout ça et ensuite un master 1
justine laberge et web
tu sais quoi quand les types sont très
longs c'est de la merde et il a payé et
on tourne et qu'on annonce était à la
fac
certaines écoles payantes alors fac elle
fac j'ai pas d'argent quelles facs la
1ère étape à la grogne oui je sais
qu'ils ont tout le nord de la france en
violant demandez-lui des cov le garçon
dit ok arrêté l'école bon ça c'est le
petit bémol c'est pas un bémol c'est
évidemment extrêmement important et
c'est comme ça qu'on se réalise c'est
lewis fermé la porte à la dictature des
diplômes c'est pas non plus la vie ce
gamin là
alors je suis petit balleroy chevaux
monde et grand voile à dire qu'
énormément désigne pas j'aurais fait
exactement la même chose
voilà un joli bateau qui fait pas été
cultivées par la monnaie voilà ça m'a
servi avec aujourd'hui voilà parmi vous
peut-être conduit ce faire l'école chez
elle peut être qu'on lui apprend des
choses vont aussi libre avec son temps
maintenant les enfants sont protégés il
ya des lois qui n'est pas gage non
l'hôtel qu'elle fait ça mais c'est un
business parce qu'on a la santé l'école
qu'on écoute vous dit important le rôle
des parents c'est ça quand même bousculé
vers côté on me parle de base de fan
club de put alors vous dites quoi
aborder sociale à la viande halal et ce
même pour sa vie sociale à la rue la
lecture à l'umih et côtoyé des légendes
réel à la part la place les déchets dits
le truc le plus intelligent il faut que
je vois des enfants afin qu'ils y va pas
rester chez elle dans une lettre à l
avoir et c'est dans une boulangerie pas
là mais c'est un problème surtout du
rapport à l'écran du rapport à
l'apparence le rapport au fait que la
vie vaut mois la peine d'être vécue que
ce qu'on vit à travers les téléphones de
plus en plus et donc que les gens sont
de plus en plus isolé est bon là elle
fait des petites vidéos des divx etc
même et toute la nouvelle génération et
toute l'admiration du futur va vivre
plus à travers les écoles oui car ils
sont tout de même que c'est un problème
qui vient de saint fons des temps les
gens déjà même dans la grotte de lascaux
envoyé un personnage tout ça je pense
qu'ici s'identifier ou les grottes de
lascaux célébrant les trucs et bah on
voir les restes je pense que ici
quantifier le guerrier à l'image il a
prié peut-être même en fait l'image la
représentation qu'ils soient verts
n'avaient pas les programmes
[Rires]
nicolaï la raison un tas d'histoires
direct dans les grottes de lascaux et
moi je suis allé dans les bronches les
écrans et bail
il a raison il ya des tas n'est quà et
sait où sont les droits des sakalava je
suis les secousses à l'abordage du but
ouvert
maintenant on en rigole je suis à
l'heure les grottes de lascaux ben oui
oui j'ai fait beaucoup de visites mais
la reproduction la grotte quoi la
reproduction de la grotte
on peut dire oui que c'est une espèce de
deux formes d'art à 200 au taux
d'autosuffisance contrat fier c'est bon
c'est une manière de communiquer